you
i might check as well let's do the whole
thing yeah there you go
check one two testing one two check one
two
might check focus assist one two three
four hold on stand by
i'm gonna make myself hold his head
how's this oh yeah
check one two just in one two borders
height
check one two test one two microphone
check
one good
testing one two one two three four five
mark you get an audio out there
mark marriott mark marriott you getting
audio
good okay
battery yeah the big 50 battery yeah
it was like three or four hundred
dollars
told me today
i'm sure
what do you think
hello we did
is
what's up
no
yep
yes
for lunch
saying
you know how
okay
is
uh
really
is
you
some references
literally
thank you
oh
stuff
okay
the briefing will now begin at 5 30.
you put it out there in the universe
all right
right
um
um
oh really
hey
you
so
right
hey guys
this
so
still out there i just realized i
probably shot all them
so
foreign
father
you
thank
so
uh
you
two minute warning
thanks daddy
are you doing something around 6 30 or
uh
one two three four five one two three
four five
thank you everyone very much thank you
so as we begin labor day
weekend america's unprecedented
economic recovery continues you see
what's going on
it's been pretty amazing the united
states economy ended
today announced this morning 1.4 million
jobs last month
bringing the total to over 10.6 million
jobs created
in just four months it's a record by far
in august we added 249 000 retail jobs
174 000 leisure and hospitality jobs
and 29 000 new manufacturing jobs
the unemployment rate plummeted to 8.4
the second largest single month drop
ever recorded
surpassed only by our big decline in
june
last month we saw large declines in the
unemployment rate for african americans
hispanic americans and
asian americans very big declines we're
witnessing the fastest labor market
recovery from
any economic crisis in history
by far by contrast the last
administration had the slowest weakest
and worst recovery in american history
that was
well documented as you know this year
the united states
has seen the smallest economic
contraction of any major western nation
and we are recovering at a much faster
rate than
any other nation business confidence is
higher today in america than
in any other g7 or eu country
that covers a lot of territory so we
have the business confidence is higher
than many in any of those countries
in july retail sales not only recovered
but reached
a new all-time high so think of that
retail sales that's a very
basic statistic and it's a big statistic
it not only recovered but reached the
highest level ever auto sales have
surged to an incredible 74
since their april low and are nearly
back to their
pre-virus levels and that's been a
tremendous thing used cars and new cars
have been both doing incredibly well
mortgage applications were 27
higher in august than during the same
period last year
homebuilder sentiment reached the
highest level on record indicating that
more
high paying construction jobs are on the
way home building has been
great and lending has been really
incredible
u.s manufacturing activity reached a
19-month high in august
while my administration has fought every
day to restore prosperity however
nancy pelosi and the democrats in
congress
are holding additional china virus
relief
hostage to
to reasons that nobody understands i
guess i do i think i understand it's
called politics
and speaking of politics i think north
carolina i think that
michigan and pennsylvania and other
states they should open the governors
the democrat governor should open the
states they'll open them on november 4th
but that should open them now it's very
unfair to the people to have those
shutdowns continuing
at the level that they're continuing
democrats are insisting on a massive
taxpayer
bailout of badly run blue states
stimulus checks for
illegal aliens and the mass release of
inmates from jail
they want to release a lot of inmates
some of them for very serious reasons
they want to release them from jail they
want that part as part of a stimulus
package can you believe it
it's time for the democrats in congress
to start working across the aisle and
put the american people first now
we have 300 billion dollars in a an
account that we didn't use
300 million and we are
willing to use that i would be willing
to release it subject to congress
and use that as stimulus money and it
would go right to the
american people so we have 300 billion
dollars sitting
in an account that we didn't need
because things are going so well with
the economy
but it would be a very appropriate thing
to release that to the american people
and i am willing to do it all we need is
a sign off
but that doesn't mean that we're going
to release prisoners
some prisoners some very vicious people
actually we're not going to put them on
the streets like the democrats
want us to and we're not going to give
stimulus checks to illegal aliens they
came into the country eagerly and
now we give them a check we want to give
the checks to
the american people so remember we have
300 million it's there we don't need the
money we don't need anything just let
that money
get released to the american people
as our economy rebounds there's only one
thing that could stop the extraordinary
economic comeback and wipe out
the future of american workers and
that's what the democrats want to do
with a 4 trillion
tax hike implementing
things that will be really bad for our
country
and this will just absolutely [ __ ]
what we're doing on regulations and so
many other
uh elements of success we had the
greatest economy in history prior to the
china virus coming in now they want to
stop regulations they want to
bring up regulations to a level stop the
things that we're doing which are at a
much smaller level and bring up
regulations at a level that nobody's
ever seen before they want to do things
that will
make it impossible for any economy to
grow they want to ban fracking
and as you saw a ban ban ban and all of
a sudden he sees his polls going down
and now he says well i was only talking
about
not maybe banning fracking but he wants
to ban fracking
and it doesn't matter what he wants to
bend the people that control him want to
ban fracking
and whether it's pennsylvania texas
oklahoma
north dakota and so many other states
you can't ban fracking that would be a
disaster
ohio want to abolish
american energy i mean that's what's
going to happen adopt
disastrous trade deals and inflict a
devastating shutdown
as you know he said we want to shut it
down we would be willing to shut it down
and you don't shut down when we're
setting records and by the way we're
rounding the corner
we're rounding the corner on the virus
joe biden's blanket shut down would
collapse our economy would cause
countless deaths from suicide drug
alcohol abuse heart disease and more you
know shutdowns
cause a lot of problems a lot of very
serious problems
more so than the virus itself biden's
plan
is not a solution it's a virtual
surrender
and our country is doing so well we're
starting to do so well i think we're
going to have a great third quarter i
mean you're going to see for yourself
because the numbers will be announced
sometime prior to the election on
november 3rd
and as you know joe spent his entire
career sending american jobs to china
and other far
far away countries for 47 years
people were pillaging our country taking
our jobs taking our companies
and that's never going to change with
that
mindset and with that group
biden is not going to be standing up to
these foreign countries is not going to
be standing up maybe more importantly to
the people that run the democrat party
he doesn't have the strength to do that
he refuses even to condem
antifa a bad group a far left domestic
terrorist organization he doesn't want
to say anything bad about it
his plan to appease the domestic
terrorists is
the exact opposite of what i'm doing and
i think you saw that last night
yesterday
the u.s marshals we sent them in u.s
marshals
we were waiting for a local government
to
take care of it but they didn't do that
so the u.s
marshals went in law enforcement they
took down the antifa member who murdered
a man in the middle of a street in
portland
the suspect was killed after drawing a
weapon
when officers attempted to take him into
custody they wanted to take him in the
u.s
marshals credible people so i want to
thank them
for their strength their bravery and i
really do wish that the
mayor of portland and the governor of
oregon would
get going and stop the crime in that
city
be so easy to do well we're focused on
creating good paying jobs the
radical left is focused on unleashing by
really violent mobs and you see that
whether you're conservative a liberal
republican
democrat or independent we must all
agree the need for peace and order and
safety
under my administration law enforcement
is conducting
arrests nationwide of rioters looters
and domestic terrorists the reasons we
didn't put
chicago into our list where we're
holding back funds from
some of these states and cities that are
doing such a poor job
such an incompetent job uh a job that
nobody can even imagine how bad and
we're holding it back until they get
their act together
and we are having a lot of people in
chicago
right now and you notice that their
numbers are going down rapidly but we
have
we've deployed a lot of federal law
enforcement
inside of chicago and they're taking out
quite a few people
and they're being arrested they're being
put in jail and that's why you see those
numbers going down that's why you see
that
with respect to the mayor we did not
haul back funds in chicago
but new york is experiencing a
tremendous crime wave
in some cases up over 300 percent
and they have to do something quickly we
just spoke to mayor bowser and she's
willing to do whatever is necessary
we have very good talk with her that's
in d.c
and the other places they speak for
themselves
we're working with the state and local
authorities to comb through
hours of videotape identify and arrest
suspects and prosecute lawbreakers
we've already got over 300 in jail
and we have tremendous evidence and i
want to thank the
media for helping us out because they're
taking
different angles we have it from every
different angle you can't probably have
any better than what we've got
we see it from the sky and the ground
and
from the right and from the left so when
they say they didn't do it we say well
what's this so we get that from the
media free of charge under
operation legend we've surged federal
law enforcement to cities plagued by
violent crime the initiative has already
resulted
in tremendous success and nationwide
we have over 2 000 arrests and we don't
talk about it too much but now we might
as well
so we've arrested over 2 000
criminals the criminals and in a single
month murder rate in chicago as you know
and as i said it was cut in half
actually
so on the china virus front the
nations of europe have experienced a 38
greater excess mortality than
the united states 38 more greater
excess mortality than the united states
a lot of you don't want to report that
and if we took new york
out of the equation there's nobody even
close the job we've done is incredible
and
we don't get any credit for it but we've
done an incredible job
through operation warp speed we have
three vaccines in the final
stage of clinical trials yesterday
pfizer announced i just spoke to the
head of pfizer
great guy they announced that it expects
to have the results of its
trial very very shortly next month
but very shortly we remain on track to
deliver a vaccine before the end of the
year and maybe even before
november 1st we think we could probably
have it sometime
during the month of october and pfizer
is
uh among the leaders as you know and
it's a great company
johnson and johnson also doing very well
moderna we have some really great
companies they're all doing very well
they're all in
final stages and i think you're going to
see results that are
shockingly good finally i want to
provide you with a brief update of the
virus cases in the united states have
declined 28
nationwide over the last month and
hospitalizations and deaths have
continued to decline over the past week
very substantially decline
thanks to america's medical genius the
mortality rate has been reduced by
85 5 in april
mortality rate reduced by 85
hospital lengths of stay are one-third
of their average length
in april so the hospitalization's down
the length of stay
is way down in order to keep making
progress against the virus
we ask all americans to remain vigilant
especially over labor's
labor day you know you have the labor
day weekend
coming upon us immediately i guess we
can say pretty immediately
and we need everybody to be careful to
apply common sense and
do all of the things that we've told you
to do
as quickly as much as you can
social distancing wearing a mask when
ever the distancing is not
possible and staying like
staying with a group that you know let's
just try and get through this
one weekend and i think we have a chance
of doing that just
social distance wash your hands all of
the hygiene things that we speak about
and we're really rounding the turn and
the vaccines are coming
the therapeutics have already come but
they continue to come
the convalescent plasma has had a
tremendous
impact already you see what's happening
there and remdessevier has been
incredible so we have a lot of things
happening we have a lot of
therapeutics coming out i think from the
standpoint of common sense i guess
therapeutics to me right now you're
going to a hospital you give somebody a
shot or
or transfusion it might be a transfusion
probably more than 50 are actually
transfusions and
they'll leave the hospital shortly
thereafter i mean to me that's
more important in a certain sense in the
vaccine but the vaccines will be
great over the long term the
therapeutics over the short term and
also knowing you have the therapeutics i
think is great
from the standpoint of mind from the
standpoint of the mind
that's great so i want to thank
everybody for being here i'm going to
ask
larry kudlow to give a couple of
examples of how
strong our economy is uh
recovering how strongly it's recovering
and it's setting records at every level
and we're doing better than
every other country and we're very proud
of all of the people for
doing such an incredible job this is a v
it's a super v
again we have 300 billion dollars ready
to go all congress has to do is say use
it if they say use it
i'd like to use it without their
permission but i guess i'm not allowed
to do that i did ask that question
so congress has to just say use it all
they have to do is they use it 300
billion dollars gets immediately
put into our system and will really help
the american people there's nothing else
to do just a very quick statement
so i'm going to ask larry to come up i
want to thank
another man for being here today there's
a man that's a
incredible leader lou holtz i've known
him for a long time he's been a friend
of mine and i think i've received
letters from every football coach
almost in the nation and that's a little
exaggeration but some
some of the greats nick saban wrote a
letter
coach o and coach o is central casting i
said we're gonna have to put him in a
movie right as a football coach
he'd really be good playing a football
coach like you
and urban meyer wrote a beautiful letter
and so many of
the other great legendary coaches not
only coaches though uh
people in sports and people in life and
even
great political people recommending lou
for the
presidential medal of freedom and we've
analyzed it very closely we've looked at
all
of those recommendations we've looked at
lou's life and his career and what he's
done for charity and
the football is obvious he was a great
coach but what he's done
beyond even coaching so lou will be
getting the presidential
medal of freedom and the date is being
picked it won't be
in the too distant future lou was
married to a great woman right lou
great woman that she just passed away a
few months ago
this is an incredible woman she was
stronger i knew her
i knew her well she was stronger than
lou i think she was stronger than you i
hate to tell you you're strong too
but she was special right so i just want
to congratulate
coach luhls on
soon to receive the presidential medal
of freedom and we look forward to that
lou
thank you very much and you can stay
around and listen to larry for a couple
of seconds or
go to your friend you probably know half
of the people in the room
i'll bet they treat you better than they
treat me they treat him good
i wish you'd treat me that way larry
come on up
thanks sir appreciate it again coach
many congrats
many many congrats um just to underscore
uh the president's assessment of the
economy very strong jobs report today
8.4 unemployment rate um
1.4 million payrolls increased but
i want to add 3.8 million 3.8 million
increase in the important household
survey which aims at small businesses
particularly and from which the
unemployment is calculated
in the past four months we've generated
a 10.6 million
increase in payrolls and a 14 million
increase in households so we've restored
basically half of the jobs that were
lost
in the pandemic contraction today's
report also
included the lower wage industries and
minority groups across
the board the diffusion index was a
whopping 69 percent
so these gains are very very uh
broad-based
there's still too many people out there
still too much hardships due to many
unemployed
and we are working on that and we're
moving in the right direction
and that's why today's numbers are
encouraging and optimistic
now other areas that the president
mentioned just to underscore
we are in a housing boom there can be no
disagreement about that
sales mortgage applications prices home
starts
up 23 annually in july we're in a car
boom automobile boom
we've gone from 8.7 million in sales
to 15.2 million in sales in the recent
four months
that's a big jump as president mentioned
the leading indicator of that is used
car
sales and prices the manufacturing
indexes are very strong this
recovery includes manufacturing the isms
running in the high 50s the new order
indexes at 68
production index is 63. we had a
manufacturing report for
durables core durables
over the past three months orders of 35
shipments up 35 so these are very strong
numbers
new business applications um from 25
000 to 66 000 it's 160
gain through august and as the president
referred
consumer spending is booming we're up 84
annually over the past three months uh
my view of course um we are in a
v-shaped recovery
it is a self-sustaining recovery high
demand
increased production and manufacturing
along with uh decline in inventories
will give us a tremendous momentum going
into the second half of the year
i still reckon that the third quarter
will be at least 20 percent growth
the atlanta fed's gdp now index is close
to 30 percent
i think 20 is a good number i think the
whole second half
and next year provided that economic
policies remain
uh pro-growth and i just want to mention
one thing on the policy front
i simply don't understand the other side
wanting a four trillion dollar uh tax
increase
after a deep pandemic contraction and on
this point
i believe vast majority of economists i
don't care if you're a keynesian
demand cider supply cider you just don't
raise taxes by this amount or by any
amount really but four trillion
really picking the pockets of taxpayers
who are returning to work now and need
all the resources they can get
you just don't do it the profession
should be um
have a complete consensus on that and so
i'm quite surprised and i think that is
a potential obstacle
and people are beginning to speak about
that but all i can say is
factually the numbers are coming in very
positively
there's a lot of optimism going on more
work to be done
but um we're rolling in the right
direction here thank you appreciate it
okay thank you president trump
if i could first ask you a clarifying
question about the 300 billion
i you've ruled out doing that
unilaterally you're going to wait for
congress to repurpose it
for stimulus checks yeah what about it
oh is that correct you're you're waiting
there's a theory that i can do it uh
without the approval
but i'd rather get the approval so that
we have it
but there's a theory i could take the
300 billion it's money that we have
money that we've built up and money that
we haven't spent and i
would love to give it to the american
people as a very powerful stimulus so
yeah i i think there is a theory that i
could do it
without having to go back but i think it
would be appropriate to go back and
i would ask congress to approve it it's
a very simple approval
it's uh literally it's a one-sentence
approval
and the democrats should do that the
republicans will do that
they'd be glad to do that so we'll see
whether or not they do it okay please
lean back
uh because um mr president our
editor-in-chief john solomon had an
exclusive interview with the head of the
delaware fraternal order police chapter
um he said that they were going to
endorse you instead of their native son
joe biden
i like your response as well as the
national organization of the paternal
order police
is endorsing you as well well i'm
honored that delaware because i don't
see biden anywhere but delaware he's
uh and i like delaware too but to have
the
law enforcement in delaware give their
endorsement to me is
really a great honor it's really it just
shows you how
how pathetic the democrats are when it
comes to
crime when it comes to law and order so
would you please extend my
very great thanks it's a great honor to
get it from
delaware law enforcement we've gotten it
from
almost all law enforcement but that's
that's because every time i see biden
speak it says delaware delaware delaware
he never leaves
i'm all over the country i'm all over
the place uh
yeah please go ahead yeah go ahead
thanks mr president um
germany has said that alexi navalny the
russian opposition leader was poisoned
what do you think should be done to
russia about that what is your message
to russia about that
and how should the international
community and the united states respond
well i think we have to look at it very
seriously if it's the case
and i think we will there's nobody been
tougher in russia than i
have uh we get along i get along with
almost all countries
get along with north korea remember
we're supposed to be going to war with
north korea if hillary got elected you'd
be at war right now with north korea
that would be a very messy war very bad
war many millions of people would be
killed
in the meantime uh we've gotten along
with them we didn't get to war everyone
said that if i was elected i'd be at war
in one
week it's been just the opposite we're
doing very well in afghanistan bringing
the troops down
very low level and other things are
happening very interestingly we have a
great
peace deal going on in the middle east
actually with uae and
israel and that's been received like
probably
very few things that many people have
done it's been very well received
and we'll be having other countries
announcing soon they're joining that and
you're gonna have a lot of countries and
then a lot of countries are saying hey
why didn't you
bring us in right from the beginning
they would have loved to have been there
but they want to
they want to be in so we're doing a lot
of things i think that
i was the one that alerted
the united states and the world
nordstrom 2.
i said why is germany spending billions
and billions of dollars to russia
to get their energy from russia and then
we're supposed to protect germany from
russia what's that all about
and the sanctions and everything else at
the same time with russia we're right
now
negotiating a nuclear non-proliferation
treaty which is very important
it's a very important thing to me it's
the most important thing some people say
global warming i don't i say this is
far more important and we are the
biggest they are the second biggest
nuclear-wise china's third
they're actually a distant third but
they're building pretty rapidly
and at some point we'll include china
into those talks but we're doing very
well with russia on nuclear
non-proliferation
so i don't know exactly what happened i
think it's
it's tragic it's terrible it shouldn't
happen uh we haven't
had any proof yet but i i will take a
look
uh it is interesting that everybody's
always mentioning russia
and uh i don't mind you mentioning
russia but i think probably china at
this point
is is a nation that you should be
talking about much more so than russia
because the things that
china is doing are far worse
if you take a look at what's happening
with the world
look at what happened with the china
virus look at what they did by not
keeping that within the confines of
china they should have kept it in
the confines of china look what they've
done to
188 countries all over the world but you
never ask about china always asking
about russia
so i would be very angry if that's the
case so we'll take a look at the
at the numbers and the documents because
we're going to be sent a lot of
documents over the next
few days
outreach to the indian americans
community with a video called
four more years for you which has gone
viral among indian americans
the battleground states so my question
is would kimberly don junior and ivanka
trump who are very popular now indian
americans
would be campaigning on your behalf
among the indian americans with your
views on india's citizenship
well i didn't understand everything you
said i know india and i understood
those young people that you mentioned
they're very good young people
and i know their relationship to india
is very good and so is mine and
prime minister modi is a friend of mine
and he's doing a very good job nothing
easy
nothing easy but he's doing a very good
job
we're talking i mean while we're at it
we're talking about china and india
pretty going at it pretty good on the
border as you know
it's been very nasty it's been a very
nasty situation
and we stand ready to help with respect
to china and
india if we can do anything we would
love to get involved and help
and we are talking to both countries
about that
but i appreciate your nice sentiments
[Music]
they think a lot of india and so do i
and i think a lot of
your prime minister thank you so my
question was about indian americans
do you think they are voting for you for
are you are they supporting you
i do we had a an event in
houston as you know and it was a
fantastic event i was
invited by prime minister modi and this
was a massive this was at the
where they played football the houston
football team
and it was it was it was incredible it
was actually incredible and
the prime minister could not have been
more generous we have
great support from india we have great
support from
prime minister modi and i would think
that the people
indian people would be voting for trump
i also as you know went to
india just prior to the pandemic setting
in because india's been hit very hard
left really about a week before that
and we had an incredible time what what
we saw the people
are so incredible it's really an
incredible place an incredible country
and it's definitely big it's definitely
big but you've got a great leader and
he's
he's a great uh great person thank you
do you think
china is bullying india
i hope not i hope not but they're
certainly going at it
they're going at it much more strongly
than a lot of people even understand
yeah please go ahead
please thank you sir just to follow up
on alex i know with me
you just said yeah you haven't had any
proof yet do you have any reasons to
doubt the results from germany
i mean i don't i i hear germany uh has
made it was it definitive or almost
definitive but we have not seen it
ourselves no
but we have not seen it ourselves but uh
i would certainly be
uh okay with that they want to
do something they want to take action
shouldn't happen
shouldn't happen but again we are
working very closely with a lot of
countries and a lot of different things
uh we've taken stronger action against
russia than any other country in the
world
as you know i'll tell you president
putin would tell you that
right now but the fact that i the fact
that i get along with
russia and that i get along frankly with
everybody right now
i'm not getting along with china but
that's my choice i don't like what
happened with respect to the pandemic
with respect to the china virus i don't
like it at all
what they've done to this world and this
country and europe and every place else
is
terrible but i do get along with
with president putin
but i've been tougher on russia than
anybody else by far if you look at
the obama administration they were weak
look at the land they gave up
look at what happened with respect to
look at what happened with respect to
ukraine
such a big part of ukraine given up
during the obama
administration and i don't think they
would have done that with me
i don't think they would have done that
with me at all
we gave tank busters and they gave
pillows you ever hear that expression
they sent pillows and we sent tank
busters
to ukraine so
with that being said if we can do a
nuclear non-proliferation agreement that
would be a great thing no but i would
not be
at all happy if that were the case and
it looks like it might very well be the
case i mean based on what germany
based on what germany is saying that
seems to be the case john
mr president i want to ask you about
something you said a while back and
talked about many many times
back in 2015 you said that you didn't
think
john mccain was a hero that you prefer
people who
don't get captured uh in light of all
that's happened since then
um and all you've learned do you regret
saying that is that something you wish
you had not said i say what i say and
i never got along with john mccain i
disagreed with john mccain you know that
better than anybody frankly i wasn't a
fan
i disagreed with many of his views i
disagreed with his views on these
ridiculous endless wars i disagreed with
the way he
handled the vets the va the va is
running much better now and we
did with the mission act and the
accountability and all the things we've
done for the va he was not able to do
that but i disagreed with john mccain on
a lot of things
that doesn't mean i don't respect him i
respected him but i
really disagreed with him on a lot of
things and i think i was right i think
time has proven me right
to a large extent
thank you mr president um earlier in the
statement that you
read before questions you spoke about
how you believe
that we're as you put it rounding the
corner on the corona virus pandemic
yesterday as well and i think everybody
would love to see the pandemic come to
an end there's no doubt about that
but i wanted to ask you about a forecast
that has come out from the ihme
at the university of washington and they
are forecasting by january the 1st
of next year that we'll have 410
000 american deaths from coronavirus
which is
225 000 from where we are right now
so can you explain how you see us
rounding the corner based upon that
projection
uh if i didn't close up our country if i
didn't stop
china highly infected from coming in but
didn't stop europe from coming in
far sooner than anybody else including
dr fauci and
others wanted to and dr fauci was very
nice he said
president trump made a great decision we
would have far
more than that but maybe even more
importantly if i didn't close up we
would have
instead of the number that you mentioned
or whatever it may be it were
about 180 we would have
perhaps one and a half or two million
deaths right now
if i went a different direction which
some people wanted me to do
and i decided not to do it we'd have 2
million deaths
now a lot of countries don't report
their deaths obviously china's not
reporting because they had
far more than we did china had far more
deaths than we did in my
opinion just my opinion but they don't
report
their deaths or they don't report them
accurately and i could i don't want to
embarrass other countries but i can tell
you there are other countries where the
death toll is far higher than the united
states but
they don't report to us we report it to
a level that
nobody reports it uh we also do testing
in cases i watch your
broadcasts and your read your
information your
media outlets very very carefully and i
look at
the word cases and the reason you know
it's i say it a hundred times nobody
wants to
pick it up but we do testing at a level
that nobody ever dreamed possible we
have the best tests that we have by far
the most test
actually india as per your question
before
india is number two and they've done a
good job but they're
about 40 million tests behind us
and they're a country of 1.5 billion
people
now because of all these tests we have
far more cases
if we cut our cases in half if we if we
cut our testing in half
we'd probably have about half the number
of cases if we cut it down to levels
there are some countries that
don't test they test when somebody walks
into a hospital that's the test you get
they walk into a hospital they're sick
that's your test
we have tested more and and better
and you just see where we now have
millions of tests coming in from
a certain company that's done a
fantastic job and it's going to be
anywhere from 5 minutes to 15 minutes on
the spot very accurate test
but if we had much less testing no
testing we would have
you wouldn't be reporting cases but you
saw this i don't want to go over the
statistics you all wrote it down but you
see how we're doing compared to the rest
of the world and you see and if you took
out new york which has been a tragic
situation
with the amount of people that died in
the u.s you can't take out a major state
in the u.s it's still a part of the
united states new york is
i'm just taking it to the poison i'm
just saying
new york has been in particular
run whether it's badly and competently
whether it's unfortunate and i
appreciated
governor cuomo saying that i've done a
phenomenal job and he said very
good things said bad things too you know
later on when he had no real
other choice but if you took out new
york from those numbers
uh you can multiply our tremendous
success by
by a lot but look the bottom line is
that
the job we've done on 19 or
the china virus china plague
call it whatever you want and a lot of
different names
but it's been incredible we've also
helped a lot of other countries
especially with ventilators
because we are now you know we build
ventilators a level that nobody ever
thought possible
so uh forecast being accurate
the one that i cited for you yeah if we
didn't do what i said we would be at 2
million deaths right now taking that
into account it's just going forward no
they're not taking that into account
i had a choice to make if we made the
wrong choice
the number that you have which is less
than other countries but the other
countries don't report deaths
they don't report them to the extent and
they're not accurate you know that and
so do i
because we have you take a look at some
of the things happening in certain other
very large countries
first of all we're a very large country
but you take a look at
things happening with respect to the
reporting of deaths in other
countries and i say uh
give me a break so it's been amazing but
we made some moves at the beginning
china
big europe big but the biggest of all
was
closing it down understanding the
disease and we did and now we know it's
the elderly it's
especially elderly if they have heart
diabetes if they have problems
and we're watching it and we're watching
it very closely and by the way we're
doing super testing
with respect to that super testing uh
but if we did it a different way instead
of the number that you said but
basically the number that we're at now
is approximately 180
000 we'd be at 2 million people right
now could be higher than that
i don't know anything about the russian
vaccine i'm not sure we have our vaccine
and
our vaccine is uh i think it's going to
be the standard it's going to be
great these companies are incredible
they've come up with the great vaccines
over the years and
that's the vaccine that uh probably most
of the people in this room are going to
want to take right thanks mr president a
quick
clarification of my question the 300
billion dollars is that from the
main street lending program or is that
from a different person where are you
it's sitting in an account has not been
spent
but we're willing to spend it no we're
willing to spend it i'd like to get
approval from congress
there's a theory that i don't have to do
that but i'd rather be upfront and i'd
like to get
approval from congress let it go
directly to the people it would be a
great stimulus
it's actually more stimulus than we're
asking for in terms of pure stimulus
this would be pure stimulus
i wouldn't have to let prisoners go some
very
evil prisoners go like think of it
the democrats in order to get what they
want and in order to give us what we
they're talking about allowing prisoners
to be
released prisoners that we don't want to
be released
so in order to that that we get money to
the american people
they want to say release prisoners and
and other things like that that are very
bad
and we just can't do that we don't want
to do that and then just to
follow on john's question i know you
spoke earlier about the atlantic story
and you've referenced the number of
administration officials who have come
out
to support you know we have 11 people i
was just told
i was just we have 11 people there is
nobody that feels
more strongly about our soldiers our
wounded warriors
our soldiers that died in war than i do
it's a hoax just like the fake dossier
was a hoax
just like the russia russia russia was a
hoax it was a total hoax
no collusion just like so many other
things
it's a hoax and you'll hear more of
these things
totally unrelated as we get closer and
closer to election
the magazine is a failing magazine and
nobody called me nobody called me from
the magazine said you have a comment
about it no they just write whatever
they want to write
because they figure you can't get sued
you can't get sued but it's very
it's a very hard bringing lawsuits but
we have many witnesses
and it's a total it's a total
it's just a continuation of the witch
hunt so that it can hopefully
affect the election but the american
people are too smart
so whether it's the fake dossier that
turned out to be a total fraud
or so many other things so many other
things have turned out
i've been under investigation from
before i even get elected
these people have gone after me more
than any president in the united states
in history
in the history of the united states and
it's a shame
it's a shame and despite that we've done
more in the first three and a half years
than any administration
there's been no administration that's
done more when you add it all up there's
been no
despite all of the horrible political
games that have been played
but there's nobody that's been
that's been able to do what i've done
and that includes the great mission act
because what obama passed was a joke
it was a joke and we took it to a level
that nobody thought possible
and that includes accountability so uh
it's a disgrace that somebody's allowed
to
write things like that uh it could have
been you know a lot of times the sources
aren't sources that don't exist
and sometimes the sources are just
people that are disgruntled
former so-called employees my question
is sort of about that i mean the notable
voice that's been missing from the
denials
is your former chief of staff john kelly
who was obviously
intimately involved in this what how are
we supposed to read the fact that
i know john kelly he was with me didn't
do a good job had no temperament
and ultimately he was petered out he got
he was exhausted
this man was totally exhausted he wasn't
even able to function
in the last number of months he was not
able to function
he was sort of a tough guy by the time
he got
eaten up in this world it's a different
world than he was used to
he was unable to function and i told him
john you're going to have to go
please give me a letter of resignation
and we did that
and now he goes out and badmouths now
there are people that are
jealous there are people that are upset
that they're not here anymore
there are people we've done an
incredible job the virus came in and now
we're doing an incredible job again
we're going to build it up bigger than
it was before the virus came in
but uh i don't know that it was him i
haven't seen that i mean i see anonymous
but it could have been a guy like a john
kelly
because he was because just so you
understand
he was a very
you look at some of his news conferences
what happened to him he got eaten alive
he was unable to handle the pressure of
this job this job
was a tough job mark meadows doing a
great job
but kelly was unable to do that and as
far as that day i mean we have
so much proof as to going to the
we i went to paris and the environs
and i was all set to go they had a
rainstorm the likes of which you've
rarely seen
the fog was so great it was it was as
dense as i've ever seen
and i almost knew that you couldn't use
the helicopter and because they had to
drive through i guess certain parts of
paris
the secret service who by the way we
have people
here that were on the trip they're
writing a report
unable to even think about it and i said
nope i want to go
i insist on going it would have taken us
forever
the paris police said please you can't
do this they'd have to shut down
various parts of paris and it just was
not a possible situation
the helicopter would have been very
quick they had the helicopter all set
but
the helicopter could never fly in that
kind of weather
so and that turned out and that's all
documented by the way
we have all of the information from and
probably will release that
information but i think it's a shame
when a second rate magazine i don't read
it i know very little about this
magazine but
when a second rate magazine can write
things like that about somebody that's
done much
so much for the military can write
things like that
and get away with it when you actually
ask questions on it
it's a disgrace and you ought to be
ashamed of yourself and let me just tell
you
i watched the interview with sleepy joe
biden
and he didn't ask questions you didn't
ask questions like that read the
questions yes
they were like meant for a child those
questions were meant for a child
smiles on faces of reporters not like
you
and you there were smiles on the request
what do you think take a look at those
questions that they asked him
they were not meant for a grown-up they
were meant for a child
so i just want to just tell you i just
want to tell you
it's a disgrace because you look at what
i've done for the united states military
i love those people i've gotten them pay
raises when they didn't get
anything near what i've been able to do
and i've rebuilt
2.5 trillion dollars i've rebuilt the
united states military now we're
including space force
nobody's done more for them and then
when i have to have
a report read like that from a
third-rate magazine that's not going to
be in business much longer i look at
that
and i think it's a disgrace and then
when i watch
biden getting asked
questions that it really meant for a
child
to answer anybody could answer and i
look at the level
of question that you people ask i mean
honestly it's disgraceful
so i want to thank you all very much we
appreciate it and
we're doing very well we're very very
proud of what's happened with
respect to the economy and i think that
before the election you're going to see
a third quarter announced the third
quarter will be at a level that our
country has never seen before
next year we're going to have a year
that was better
than last year and i feel very certain
it'll be better than last year it'll be
the greatest year we've had
and the whole reason this is working out
this way is because we set a foundation
for this country like we've never had
before
so next year is going to be a fantastic
year but remember this the third quarter
is going to be announced sometime prior
to the election
by a few days actually and i think it's
going to be record-setting type
numbers on gdp and other things thank
you all very much
sir
how was that
you